when you landed in amsterdam you had
your phone
did you have messages from andrew
no if i went missing for three days
my phone would be dead from him trying
to tell me
yes and the other way around amira had
the other cast members playing
90 day detectives and like now i'm
confused like
him look like nice guy after a number of
claims she made against andrew
just didn't add up we're just really
curious because we all want to hear his
side of the story
but you don't want him to be in here
with us so it's kind of upsetting for
everybody here because we can't get that
well get this amira also revealed that
she's moved on from andrew
and guess where her new man is from he
is from
the u.s
you try again only a 90-day cast
would give that oh we get it type of
reaction
because i was sitting at home like what
why are you doing this again
and why so soon she basically told on
herself
but if i'm to be honest this is the most
interest i've had in andrew and amira's
storyline
all season so we're gonna dive into it
plus mike's best friend shut down
natalie's accusations
that she and mike got intimate the night
before her wedding
no no we've never been romantic but that
wasn't
the big news here she also opened up
about a
nasty fight she had with natalie the
first day they met on facetime
she asked me if all american women were
[ __ ] or if it was just me
yes you heard that right and that was
just the tip
of the iceberg we'll get to the rest in
just a few
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissa
let's go ahead and jump right into the
drama that unfolded on part two of the
season eight tell all
kicking things off with the cast
doubting amira's claims
against andrew i'm very stressed out
it's okay yeah
now because both amira and andrew can
come off a bit
dramatic at times it's already hard to
know who's telling the truth
it made it even harder after a told
producers that andrew couldn't be on set
if they wanted her to talk andrew i
don't think she's gonna change her mind
i have to go home i'll take my jacket
i really would like to hear your side of
things you're not gonna get it man
andrew leaving kind of backfired on
amira
because when her stories had a few holes
in them
the cast was left to try to piece
together the truth on their own
and in the end it didn't make her look
too good
i would never call her a liar because i
don't know the story but the story
seemed bogus to me
all the confusion started when amira
explained what happened after she tried
to meet andrew in mexico
so they can quarantine and enter the u.s
i arrived in mexico city
and at the immigration i handed my
passport
and next thing i know i was in the back
room in the airport
and then they opened the prison cell
door to me i spent three days two nights
love
tapping that's it did they tell you why
they were detaining you
amira they never ever told me
anything during those three days i don't
understand how calm that they don't tell
you why it's unlegal they need to tell
you why they're deporting you i don't
understand it's mexico they don't care
yeah even in mexico they're like no
doesn't make sense to me at all it
doesn't make sense to me either i don't
get that
thank you okay to give amira the benefit
of the doubt
the reason why her story probably
doesn't make sense here
is because everyone's experience with
being detained
could vary i don't know that for sure
and i
don't want to find out but that could be
the case
now what did sound fishy to me is how
she said she didn't receive
any text messages from andrew after
immigration sent her back to europe
i got no messages asking me baby
are you are you safe did you land
no the whole three days you were in
detention he knows you're in mexico city
and then for three days there's radio
silence
you don't talk to him he doesn't talk to
you and then when you got
out of detention and you got your phone
back you had
no messages from those three days
i have barely nothing now she said
barely nothing
my phone was not full of message so
something i want to hear his side of the
story too like what's him trying to do i
want andrew to be here to explain
himself
if that's true that's crazy that is
insane
you know there is nothing like a good
old receipt
because amira tried to make it seem like
andrew didn't care
and we visually saw that that was not
the case
here is the episode when he was freaking
out after he learned she was detained
this is security for the airport right
do
you speak english
pablo's studying less hablar is studying
less
no every minute that amira sits in there
is a minute in which i am letting her
down and ultimately
uh love is fading see
if the other 90 day couples actually
watched the show
they would have been able to point this
out and her phone probably wasn't full
of messages from andrew
because he knew she had no connection
her dad even said that
no any collection her phone is still
still freezing the problem here is that
she tried to paint andrew as this
horrible person
instead of allowing him to be there and
tell his side of the story
so we can make that determination
ourselves
she said she didn't want to face him
because she was scared
she was scared that he was going to
scream at her because he would scream at
her
often and like now i'm confused like him
look like
nice guy like like like calm down and
like
never like believe him yell like not the
kind of guy yes
and i feel like she's like like shaking
i'm gonna have a panic attack
i would have let him sit right there and
show his true colors
he can't jump through the monitor i get
that you have to protect your piece
but if that was what she was trying to
do she shouldn't have showed up to the
tell-all
at all i gave him everything i had
in that relationship i loved him
and then i come back to france after
serbia's nightmare i see he is back
on the dating site he met me
after you returned from serbia yes
did y'all catch natalie's reaction it
was hilarious
according to amira she knew he was back
on the site because she had his email
address
and a notification popped up but then
she reveals she's dating this new man
who she's so in love with from the us
so it sounds like she was quick to get
back on the dating site too
but let me ask you have you moved on
from this relationship
so actually it took a lot of time for me
to
go back to dating i was really
heartbroken
but now i'm finally happy again and i'm
in love with someone
okay tell us about him where are you
from from
where is he from where are you coming to
america yeah where is he from
america he is from the u.s
let's just move on okay mike's friend
sarah revealed some shocking
yet not so shocking news about natalie
here's what she said went down the first
time they met
so i was taking him to pick up my
wedding cake
and michael asked me if i wanted to meet
natalie over facetime and i
said sure why not and she introduced
herself and she said hi and she told me
congratulations
and then she asked me if um all american
women were [ __ ] or if it was just me
oh no i didn't say it she said
natalie was acting like a guilty kid and
she didn't say it
who would make that elaborate story up
and based off of the things that natalie
has said in the past
it sounds about right but she continued
to deny it
sorrow i know i'm right i never said it
oh and
that was said and then we proceeded to
have a screaming match with each other
because
i didn't take well to being talked to
like that and
i said a lot of horrible things and she
said a lot of horrible things and at
that point mike hung up the phone
how fair is that ladies and men
we cannot be out here allowing our
insecurities
to have us cursing out someone who
doesn't even want
what we have when sean asked mike what
he heard
of course he played it safe by saying he
doesn't remember
after this all i could think was maybe
it was a good thing
they didn't have anyone at their wedding
because it seems like everybody other
than uncle bo
and tamara would have objected his mom
doesn't like his wife his best friend
doesn't like his wife i mean
that's a lot that is a lot
alright 90 day fans fam it's been fun
but that's a wrap for season 8 of 90 day
fiance
next week some of our fan favorites are
back for happily ever after
so make sure you stick with e.t because
we are covering it all
see you next time